thank you we sincerely appreciate your
interest
in hearing from us about critical
considerations when choosing an rtpcr
assay
for detection of the sars code 2 virus
perkin elmer was one of the first
organizations to develop and deploy
nucleic acid detection kits in response
to the disease outbreak
we would like to take this opportunity
to share our experience in assisting
people
on the front line of fighting the virus
proclaimer offers nucleic acid and
immunoassay-based solutions
for starch scope 2. this session will be
on
nucleic acid based testing
we will start by discussing the critical
success factors for implementing
south scope 2 testing solutions in labs
followed by introduction to the
different components of prognomere's
nucleic acid detection workflow as it
relates to
vital rna isolation pcr setup and
finally
the assay for nucleic acid detection
itself
vital dynamics in infected patients are
yet to be fully
understood a publication in the landsat
back in march
reported that vital load tends to
correlate with the severity of infection
other reports support the possibility of
source co2 transmission
from persons who are pre-symptomatic or
asymptomatic
therefore a highly sensitive rtpcr
assay with the ability to pick up low
viral load
reliably is critical to accurately
diagnose and reduce the spread of
infection
in response to a survey conducted by the
association for
molecular pathology labs report that
supply chain interruptions
have had a significant impact on their
testing capacity
with over 85 percent of labs reporting
that
these interruptions have had negative
effects such as delay
in turning around test reports and
ultimate decline
in test requests received over time due
to their inability to meet
turnaround time obligations while
all lab types were reporting challenges
academic medical centers and community
hospital labs
reported the most severe barriers
including
limited supply of testing kits and
reagents
such an overwhelming message from over
200 responses
across all lab types indicate that a
steady supply chain
is needed to implement and sustain
routine testing
the same survey also reported that
sample throughput
ranges from a few hundred tests to
greater than 500 tests a day
over ninety percent of the labs plan to
increase throughput in the next
two to three months by adding platforms
shifts or expanding workforce
with the fall season fast approaching in
the u.s there is an increasing need to
run
a flexible operation to stay in sync
with fluctuating demand
automation is a critical need to
accomplish this without increasing staff
and their exposure to the risk of lab
acquired infections
during high volume processing
lastly it is very important to find the
right partners to ensure that all
components of the operation
work in harmony with each other very
often providers
with a broad portfolio covering multiple
components of the workload
simplify life for the lab manager they
offer
a simplified ordering process better
visibility to availability of materials
required for sample processing
and dependable technical support through
a single point of contact
at a high level there are three steps in
the nucleic acid testing process
sample collection sample isolation and
nucleic acid detection
the key emerging 360 platform is
perkinalmer's magnetic bead-based
isolation method that is ideally suited
for automated sample processing which
our customers have communicated as being
extremely important in such emergencies
sample isolation plate setup and pcr
setup can be facilitated by modular
janus workstations
automated processing culminates in the
detection of the virus
using the real-time pcr kits from
prokanomer
as a reference point labs looking to
process 1000 samples
in a workday we'll be looking to use
the setup you see on the screen with one
key magic 360 unit two janus
workstations
and four thermal cyclers
the chemogenic vital dna rna 300 kit
h96 is designed for automated isolation
from 300 microliters
of oropharyngeal swab nasopharyngeal
swab
bronchoalveolar leverage sputum plasma
or serum
using the kimoji 360 platform equipped
with a chemic 96 broad headset
the isolation process takes
just 60 minutes for 96 samples
followed which the eluded cell scope to
rna is ready for subsequent analysis via
rtbcr
the figure here shows an amplification
plot from an rtpcr
developed by an end user targeting the
rsrp or e-gene
the full solution for vital isolation
comprises the key magic 360 instrument
the kimojic 96 bar headset and chemic
vital dna rna
300 kit h96
as mentioned before the 96 volt format
is well suited for high throughput
nucleic acid isolation
offers reliable protocols for multiple
applications
as well as convenient sample loading and
online buffer dispensing
the camergic 360 uses transiently
magnetized rods
to attract the beads after binding to
the nucleic acids
this feature and the concerted rotation
of the rods
allow optimum sample mixing during the
homogenization and washing steps
thereby increasing the yield and purity
of the extracted nucleic acid molecules
the transfer of the magnetic beads
between tubes minimizes the possibility
of sample contamination
between purification steps
the liquid handling steps are met by two
configurations of the janus instruments
are quite straightforward
the first configuration is an automated
alternative for a laborious sample
reformatting process the instrument
increases sample processing efficiency
by reformatting 192 samples in 48
minutes
it also reduces exposure from hazardous
sample handling and improves sample
integrity by reducing manual errors
the second configuration of the janus
instrument aids in
increasing efficiency by preparing two
pcr plates in 16 minutes
the instrument reduces hands on time and
like its
sample reformating counterpart improves
sample integrity by reducing manual
letters
on the 24th of march this year the u.s
fda
authorized emergency use of the
perkinelmer new coronavirus nucleic acid
detection kit
for detection and or diagnosis of the
virus that causes corbin 19.
the fda also granted procurement's
request to utilize the key magic vital
dna rna 300 kit
h96 on the key magic 360 equipped with a
key magic rod head
set 96 we encourage you to visit the
fda's website listed here to access the
instructions for use
fact sheet for health care providers and
patients for additional details
the protein elmer new coronavirus
nucleic acid detection kit
uses tachman based real-time pcr
technique to conduct in vitro reverse
transcription
of source scope to rna dna amplification
and
fluorescence detection the assay targets
specific genomic regions of cells cov2
namely nucleocapsid n-gene and orf-1ab
and leverages multiplexing capacity to
enable processing of 94 samples in one
run
alongside a positive control and a
negative control
the assay includes an rna internal
control that leverages
bacteriophage ms2 to monitor the process
from nucleic acid extraction all the way
to fluorescence detection
the internal control probe is labeled
with big
fluorescent dye to differentiate its
fluorescent signal from seroscope to
targets the tachman probes
for the two amplicons are labeled with
the fam and rocks fluorescence dice
respectively to generate target specific
signals
the assay has been optimized to produce
results with high analytical sensitivity
and specificity
the results confirm a limit of detection
of 7.142
copies per mill for the orf 1ab target
and 23.380 copies per ml for the end
target
in autopharyngeal spot matrix using the
k-magic 360 platform
the results also confirm a limit of
detection of 8.323 copies per mil
for the order of 1ab target and 27.2
copies per ml for the end target in
mesopharyngeal swab matrix
using the k-magic 360 platform
in addition to the significant increase
in output from existing factories and
production lines
perkin elmer has set up new
manufacturing lines across the globe to
meet the growing demand for nucleic acid
testing
the latest addition to this capacity
expansion plan is the source cove ii
real-time rtpcr assay manufactured in
turkey number finland this is a ce
marked real-time pcr technique
to conduct in vitro transcription of
source code to rna
dna amplification and fluorescence
detection
each kit has four components with
material to process
96 samples in approximately 60 minutes
using 14 microliters of extracted
nucleic acid
as input the assay includes probes for
human rna target that is used
as an internal control to monitor the
process from nucleic acid extraction
to fluorescence detection the assay
includes
probes
that as previously mentioned cover both
the intel
as the internal control and um the
targets
of the assay this test is marketed as an
in vitro diagnostic device by meeting
the requirements
of the european in-vitro diagnostic
directive and is available
to ship immediately
in summary turkey number is very proud
and honored for the opportunity to
support
the laboratory community in this
critical time with standardized workflow
solutions
for high throughput detection of the
cell scope 2 virus
to recap perky number cell scope 2
testing workflow
offers a highly sensitive assay and a
comprehensive workflow including
chemogenic nucleic acid extraction
system that can process 96 samples
in an hour in janus liquid handling
workflow stations that mitigate the
risks
associated with sample reformatting
isolation setup and pcr setup
ultimately increasing sample processing
capacity
these products can ship immediately and
future availability
is backed by a strong supply chain from
from redundant factories
set up across multiple continents
we understand that many labs have
adopted a 24 7 operating model
to do our part perkin hammer has a
dedicated support line that is monitored
around the clock
to help you in whatever small way we can
thank you very much for your attention